foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we've got malibam in
the studio hi everybody and guess who's
back ladies and gentlemen
yeah on the private podcast we'll talk
to him about his wonderful Detroit trip
he was speaking to a bunch of middle
school students high school students
we'll talk about that whole thing but
coming up on this free public minimal
episode we're talking to a listener
about why it's so difficult to let go we
also have an outstanding lightning round
segment a live stream question actually
a couple live stream questions for you
and a listener tip you can check out the
full almost three hour maximal edition
of episode 378 where we answer four
times the questions and we dive deep
into several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcasts and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
suck let's start with our callers if you
have a question or comment for our show
give us a call
406-219-7839 or better yet you can email
a voice memo with that beautiful sound
quality to podcasts at the
minimalists.com our first question today
is from Kat my name is Kat I'm from New
Orleans Louisiana I am a pretty new
follower of the minimalists and I was
getting so much value out of the public
podcast that I decided to become a
private podcast member I am 31 and the
house that I've been renting I moved in
when I was 22 so I've lived there for
almost a decade
um which is I realize kind of rare for
someone my age I know most of my friends
and family have moved around a lot but I
really
have loved being kind of steady and
stable where I am
um the thing is is my place has been so
comforting and so safe
um you know and has been such a
sanctuary for me
throughout my 20s
um and you know my landlord lives in the
other half of the duplex and he's been
great he you know makes sure I'm safe he
takes care of things when they're broken
I'm actually like really close with his
family I babysit his daughter sometimes
um and he deducts it from my rent and so
I've just developed such an attachment
to this place that I've been living in
for almost a decade um almost a third of
my life
um that it's hard for me to let go of it
um and I am ready for a change I'm ready
to move to a different city about an
hour away I want to be closer to my
partner I want to hopefully own a home
that's kind of the goal although there's
a possibility I may have to rent for a
little while longer before I can buy
um but yeah the idea of
changing and I'm really attached to my
place like my physical house the idea of
somebody else living in it it's like you
know no this is my house like I have
three cats that I've become you know
like obviously they'll come with me but
like this has been their home too and
they're basically my children
and I just I'm having a really hard time
letting go and I'm ready to move I'm
ready to move on and I used to think
that the problem was like all the stuff
I had accumulated was the main reason I
was anxious about moving but as I've
you know started to follow you all and
started to declutter I started to
realize that it's not so much the stuff
like getting rid of stuff has been
really easy it's actually detaching and
letting go of the place the physical
place I'm in and also just like the
uncertainty of what if this new wherever
I end up is not as safe or secure or
you know if I end up having to rent what
if I have a landlord that's not as
accommodating and not as you know
present and attentive and and safe
um or treats me like family you know or
what if you know I can't buy so I have
to do that and you know I just think of
all these what ifs and but I also think
about the fact that like I'm ready for a
change I'm ready for something new
um I work remotely so like moving is not
really going to affect my work life very
much so I just was hoping for some
guidance and anything that might help me
make this transition and let go of
my home and move to a new one
Chad I'm gonna tell you something I
think you already know
letting go is difficult
but clinging creates more difficulties
now you probably recognize that with
your stuff and she even said like I had
an easier time getting rid of the stuff
of course you did in the rear view it's
always easy that now that's in the past
but in the moment I'm sure there were
some things that were relatively easy to
let go of and some things where it's
like oh I know I have an attachment an
irrational attachment to this thing
but I'm having trouble letting it go and
eventually
something changed the thing didn't
change
you didn't change but the story you were
telling yourself about the thing changed
if I get rid of this I'll free up more
space or huh maybe I don't actually use
this as much as I thought I did or you
know what I was holding on to this just
in case but I've had it for three years
and I haven't used in the last two and a
half years and I'm going to give myself
permission to let go because Letting Go
means what
well only you get to decide what that
what is what are the benefits for you
right now you can't see the benefits of
moving outweighing the benefits of
staying for you well why is that because
of the fear of the unknown but of course
every fear is the fear of the unknown
there's really no fear of the known
because even if you have a fear of the
known there's some unknown behind that
known and so every fear that you are
experiencing is a fear of the unknown
and so that's what terrifies you now
it's what terrifies people when they're
letting go of the stuff what if what if
those two words came up again and again
and again what if this happens what if
that happens yes a million hypothetical
things can happen there's no reason to
be worried about those things you can
bring up legitimate concerns that might
steer you in the correct direction but
you can bring up a million what-ifs that
will merely paralyze you because you'll
be paralyzed by fear TK what are your
thoughts yeah to build on that the
question is not
will you let go the question is what
will you let go because either you'll
let go of what's holding you back or by
refusing to let that go
you'll let go of the life of possibility
that's calling you forward and that's
the problem with clinging when you cling
to the stuff that's weighing you down
you compromise the stuff that makes you
come alive and I would ask what is the
vision that makes me come alive what is
it that compels me not from a place of
necessity not from a place of
familiarity but what is it that compels
me in the sense that it beckons me to a
life of adventure it summons me to bring
forth what is within me it drives me to
be who I know I was born to be I'll tell
you when we left Charleston it was
incredibly difficult most people in fact
hardly anyone even asked about it
because they just assume that since we
lived in California before we're like so
much happier about the geography now but
over the four years of living there we
fell in love with it man we fell in love
with our place and our neighborhood and
our community and so on and I genuinely
felt like the place we lived is a place
I could retire I I could live there for
the rest of my life and be happy and I
think my wife would agree with me we
didn't leave because we were unhappy
with where we were
we left because there is the passion and
the Curiosity towards something that is
unknown and you know what's funny
speaking from the other side I can
honestly say without any sense of loss I
like the place that we lived in much
better than the place we live in now and
the place we live in now I'm grateful
for it but I like the place we live in
better I think it looked nicer I think
it felt nicer I like the old
neighborhood I'm grateful for where we
are now and even then I can say
a life of freedom from regret is
possible even when you still like some
of the things you left behind a little
bit more than some of the things you
move forward to because it's not about
the place that you lived or the
neighborhood you lived in or the
neighbors that you had alone it's also
about the possibilities that you wanted
to call forth from your own soul and if
you just compare a familiar place that
you know works for you with a complete
unknown right when it comes to that
unknown you're going to be able to think
about every possible problem a possible
landlord that you might not like and
there's no way you can prove that that's
not going to happen right a possible
neighbor that you might not like there's
no way you can prove that that won't
happen and you have all of those things
known in your current situation so the
unknown is almost always going to lose
but let's just assume that this place
you're living is the nicest place you're
ever going to be and you're going to
like the new place and the new landlord
and the new neighbor a little bit less
is that what you're living your life for
are you living your life life to make
sure that you avoid ever having a
neighbor that's not perfect or a
landlord that's not perfect if that's
all your life is about by all means stay
but is there anything more
is there something that you want to
bring forth from your soul that might be
worth risking a neighbor that you don't
know I want you to have the best
Neighbors in the world I want you to
have the best landlord if that's what
you're going to have but at the end of
the day life is about who you want to be
it's about how you want to show up it's
about what you want to explore it's
about the adventure that you want to
create and I wouldn't let having all of
my aunts my questions answered about the
place I'm currently in hold me back from
getting those questions that are still
burning in my heart answered you got to
get those questions answered because if
you don't that's what regret is
man Breaking Up Is Hard I mean I'll tell
you what I think about relationships in
my life and
even when they were pernicious and I
knew they weren't good I was still
clinging and it took me took me a while
to let go this is this is the opposite
because she doesn't want to leave she
likes where she's at this isn't a
pernicious place right right so I agree
with you TK about getting clear on what
her vision is like it's always okay to
run away from something as long as you
know what you're running towards and
that analogy doesn't quite fit here
because she's not running away from this
she's she's moving on to bigger and
better potential uh possibilities that
what if Milburn it makes me think of the
essay that we have on our website about
you know what's the best that can happen
and all those what-ifs we just put all
these negative scenarios in yeah and we
start to get you know make ourselves
scared and paranoid and we don't ever
consider what's what's actually the best
thing that could happen yeah what if I
really enjoy this 300 more we don't ask
that question it's just what if my
landlord isn't kind to me right yeah and
part of that is what we're focusing on
right absolutely you often hear me talk
about my neighbors on both sides who are
awesome uh literally on the left side of
me it's like these peaceknit hippies who
are amazing wonderful people and then we
have like some conservative Christians
on the right side of me uh and these
people get along so well with each other
it's beautiful and then across the
street from us we have what might be
considered a dysfunctional family
probably not as dysfunctional as the
family Ryan or I grew up in yeah but I
don't focus on what's going on over
there even though the police will show
up occasionally and and they're yelling
from time to time or the one of the
boyfriends comes by and they're in the
street getting into arguments oh wow I
don't focus on that as much because I
know that I have these other things what
if my neighbors here and here are
awesome or what if the neighbors across
the street because here's the truth it
doesn't really affect me either way what
does affect me is the story I tell
myself about it and I like what you're
saying here Ryan it's not even a breakup
with the place it's she's graduating
yeah and so cat you're graduating from
this apartment and it's beautiful I
remember the remember the last the
second last place I lived in Dayton the
beautiful Loft space oh man that was
great I just saw a picture of yesterday
for the video Jordan I'm gonna send you
this picture of me and Ryan in my
they'll put it right here above my left
shoulder me and Ryan we're 29 years old
December of 2010 we were getting ready
to start we were 10 days away from
starting the minimalists.com we had been
planning it for a few months and there
was a photo of us in my apartment
together and it's my favorite place I've
ever lived it's still to this day yeah
yeah still my favorite thing yeah and it
was 900 a month yeah I know this massive
beautiful Loft downtown Dayton Ohio and
yet I left there why well a couple
reasons one is getting out of debt was
really compelling to me leaving the
corporate world was compelling to me and
so I couldn't even afford the 900 bucks
a month so I found an apartment that's
500 bucks a month in Dayton and then
eventually Ryan and I left Dayton to go
explore more and I really enjoyed the
last apartment I lived in Dayton and
that was wonderful then we moved to this
cabin on the side of a mountain in the
middle of nowhere
it wasn't our intent to stay there for
very long we were there for like five
months and then we were gone we went to
the next place it was about moving
forward was much more compelling to me
than holding on to this place and I
think that's the problem with Nostalgia
Nostalgia becomes a 2d rose-colored rear
view yes everything was perfect and
beautiful in that apartment in that lot
whatever it was that's the story I tell
myself yeah but I could tell myself that
same story about what's coming next yeah
that Nostalgia Keeps Us stuck in a lot
of ways like my favorite place that I
ever lived in was the one uh that Mariah
and I lived in right before we left
Missoula that like Studio Loft it was
had nice big Windows mountains stunning
views stunning views I mean absolutely
stunning views and um I think about that
place a lot and I'm I I don't know if I
I mean I definitely miss it but I don't
dwell on missing that place and
sometimes I look back I'm like oh maybe
I should subletted it and at least had
an opportunity to move back in there but
you know I know that for me and Mariah
to move on from that place like there's
so much more for us out there
um especially you know here in La like
there's so much more that I'm willing to
kind of let go of the the the love or
the really really strong like that I had
for that place so yeah cat um it's all
about that perspective what what are you
um what are you going to obtain or what
do you have the chance of obtaining by
moving away from this place and that is
um yeah that's what I would say focus on
one one quick closing comment for me for
cat is trust yourself I think one of the
dangers of looking at a situation like
it's the best that you'll ever do is
that it overlooks the magic of you that
brought all of those things together and
even made that experience possible you
don't have a good landlord independently
of the kind of person that you are and
the way in which you impacted that
landlord you think that landlord allows
you to babysit their kids
independently of who you are and how you
show up that says something about the
magic of you and so many times we find
ourselves in these awesome spaces
experiencing these awesome things and we
think this is the best that it's ever
going to be completely overlooking
completely discounting the fact that
it's so awesome right now because of the
kind of person that we are when you move
on you can recreate the magic that
uniquely comes from you and other places
too never doubt your ability to create
Magic in places that are different from
where you've already been and that magic
is often far more compelling than what
she said with being steady like I
understand you want some level of
certainty
but the certainty doesn't come from your
home alone by the way that kind of
certainty is also a misnomer because the
person who owns the apartment you're in
right now could decide to sell the
building and jack up the rent so that's
not affordable they could say they want
a different tenant because they have a
family member who's sick and they need
to take care of them these are a bunch
of what ifs you could tell yourself
about your current Place well I don't
think those are empowering what-ifs but
you see your place as you said as a
sanctuary and Cat
the cool thing about a sanctuary is
there isn't just one Sanctuary you can
find the things that make your current
home your sanctuary and you can tweeze
those out and you can carry that with
you it could be physical things it could
be something about the time and location
it could be the proximity to the places
you want to go in your neighborhood
but whatever it makes your home your
Sanctuary you can create recreate that
it's like TK when you moved here and you
started you found a new church it was
like well I can only go to the one back
in Charleston
I didn't make any that would make any
sense you would feel discontent around
that but so I can find a new one yeah
and maybe I'll like it more maybe I'll
like it less that comparison isn't
really helpful either yep what is
helpful is understanding
that limiting mindset of the sanctuary
is only here where I'm living and you
can let go of that the story that I was
telling a moment ago and Ryan and I were
just talking about we wrote about in our
book everything that remains and so cat
I'd love to send you a copy of
everything that remains because
what I just told you was sort of an
attenuated version of letting go of
place letting go of the
the
chains of that particular place because
it was really comforting they were
gold-plated chains handcuffs yeah that I
was attached to right and as soon as I
feel that attachment so deep that I feel
like I need to cling to this thing
that is a sign for me to loosen my grip
and if once I loosen my grip that's
often a sign that that's okay to let go
because in order to move on
I'm gonna have to let go so cat if you
enjoy our podcast I think you'll enjoy
the audiobook version of everything that
remains or if you want the book book or
the ebook version Alabama will send one
of those to you as well I just want to
say Kat thank you so much for being a
patron that's awesome I'm so glad we had
that much value to your life speaking of
time Ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it's time for the lightning
round where we answer your questions
from Tick Tock because all the people on
Tick Tock are very mad Ryan we're so
cool oh we're so cool
why are they mad on Tick Tock I'll tell
you later okay
yeah during a talk aboutable segment
we'll talk about that now during the
lightning round this is where Ryan TK
and I answer your questions in less than
six 60 seconds we do our best to give
you something pithy a short shareable
answer that we copy and paste in the the
show notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like looks like we have a question here
today from Jay-Z I don't think wanting
nice things always equals feelings of
inadequacy excessive acquiring yes I can
see that but what's wrong with wanting
one nice thing
you know I like fancy things
[Laughter]
let's throw 60 seconds on the clock for
Ryan Nicodemus all right let's do it a
life is enhanced not defined by our
possessions so the ownership of
something doesn't make you adequate or
inadequate I think the essence of this
question is why does Desiring something
nice why does that make them inadequate
I don't think it does and Josh and I
would never make anyone feel bad for
wanting a fancy thing the question is is
um why do you want that thing and you
know what are you willing to give up for
that thing so let's say you want a nice
car that's great get a nice car if
you're really passionate about a car go
ahead and get a nice car if you can
afford it now if you can't afford it and
you tell yourself oh man you know I'm
gonna have to like work 80 hours a week
for the next five years to get this car
I don't know if I can commit to that
well then maybe that is where yeah
you've got to kind of fall back and
maybe question whether or not that
purchase is correct because now you're
giving up your time for that car so the
question isn't again if you're adequate
or inadequate with your possessions it's
really about
um what are what's your relationship
with those possessions or the what's
your relationship with the desire for
those possessions I mean I almost had it
man that's good man that's good don't
let the buzzer worry I know
we got another shot clock for TK Coleman
minimalism isn't about right versus
wrong it's about what's right for me
versus what's wrong for me when I was a
little boy my mom had me doing some
chores in the house and I remember
looking out the window and I saw some of
the other kids in the neighborhood
running around playing and I said my mom
what about them what about them do they
have chores to do and she said worry
about your story son you don't know
their story there's no faster way to
make your own story miserable than by
becoming preoccupied with other people's
story in an effort to moralize them and
what they do you don't know their story
you don't know what they need and why
they need it you don't know what they
need to get rid of and why they need to
get rid of it minimalism isn't about
moralizing about how many possessions
other people have it's about taking a
look at your life and saying how can I
optimize for the joy that I want to feel
for the adventure that I want to
experience nothing less
that was great man that was great right
on a minute
um
how was he looking at you like like come
on TK pass the ball pass the ball
we got James Harden over here oh man but
he was saying makes me think of uh you
know like I've seen bios before where
it's like you know me not my story
by the way this feels like like hearted
I'm just going through my legs that's
really looking for a shot no no idea
where I'm going I just Chuck it up with
that buzzer going on I got some words
for Jay-Z give me uh 60 Seconds
so
enjoying a thing creates Wonder
needing a thing
creates worry and so if you're asking
about what's the problem with wanting a
nice thing no problem with wanting it
but as soon as you feel like you're
incomplete without it then what you need
it to complete you and therefore
that needing has created a sort of
prison of worry in your life because
when you get the thing eventually if you
do get it now there'll be a whole new
set of worry because I need this thing
it makes it much more difficult to enjoy
it and without that Joy you don't have
the Wonder of the experience that that
thing was meant for in the first place
by the way you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
is our handle over there we'll check in
with our patreon a live stream here in a
moment but first real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
Sunday Symposium is back y'all oh yeah
heck yeah wait like a little sound
effect like
those Messiah or something that's good
with four sold out events last year and
we're moving it to quarterly right now
so our next one is March 26th only 200
seats I think there are only a few dozen
seats left at this point
um but you can just check their Sunday
symposium.com I will tell you this last
time we announced on the podcast they
went pretty quickly and so you can get
your tickets right now
sundaysymposium.com it's a live event a
gathering of open-minded dogma-free
people I don't care what your religion
is what your background is what your age
is what your socioeconomic level is
what's your level of understanding or
education is and whether you listen to r
b or not well you have to listen
well do you think Michael Jordan's
better or worse than LeBron James there
will be a quiz afterwards but these
events have been truly magical we uh on
Christmas last year we released one of
the events so if you want a taste of
that event it was called how to let go
it was our fourth Sunday Symposium our
first one of the year and I don't know
it could be our last one it could always
be the last one and so don't put it off
if you've really wanted to go to one of
these and they sold out you couldn't get
tickets beforehand now's your
opportunity 200 seats and then it's
completely full Sunday symposium.com
we'll do a live talk a discussion
there'll be uh some music beforehand a
lot of Joy some hugs afterwards nicotine
is doing any stand-up comedy for this
one
pulse polka I thought yeah
learning how to play accordion now with
the juggling yeah yeah yeah oh shoot
don't challenge me like that TK
it's just a request no no that's that's
funny so if you've been wanting to see
the minimalists alive you want to see
the three of us live
sundaysymposium.com March 26th Sunday at
noon you can get your tickets right now
Malibu let's check in with the patreon a
live stream what do you got for us we
have a question
Walsh she hi I just wanted to thank you
for the excellent audio quality of the
podcast I have unsubscribed to countless
podcasts because they seem to be
recorded through Skype or underwater and
I'm extremely sensitive to irritating
sounds I grew up in the radio industry
my dad was a broadcaster and he taught
me to appreciate sound your podcast is
the gold standard it is crystalline and
I love it for that as much as I love
your content oh also I've been a fan
since 2012 you guys have always been
awesome and you changed my life for the
better but adding TK was the best thing
you could have done not only does he
have a voice like butter but I also
agree with every word he utters
oh man she goes on to say I truly
appreciate a perspective that does not
focus just on psoicism thank you all so
much for what you do you are adding more
value to lives than you know
um well I would I want to disagree
because I don't agree with everything TK
says but I also know TK well enough to
know that he doesn't agree with
everything that he says he's willing to
be active minded enough to change his
mind even about his own beliefs hey well
I do agree with these words I love you
so much thank you so much for that
comment yeah hugs from the heart yeah
thank you so much awesome Heather thank
you and also a big shout out to
post-production Peter Professor Sean and
podcast Sean who will make the audio
sound crystalline yeah what a great
compliment because you have no idea how
much
um Josh and those men work on the sound
quality so
um you know it wasn't just stroking TK's
ego it was also stroking Josh's ego and
it deserves to be stroked
just go no further just go no further
uh speaking of I know that Heather said
that the sounds annoy her I agree with a
lot of podcasts that are they're not
really podcasts or shows they're
recorded Zoom calls essentially yeah or
underwater we should move our studio to
underwater water
now Lie from underwater yeah there are
so many pie even like there are
multi-million dollar podcasts that sound
like garbage and so thank you for
noticing that I will say this she
mentioned the annoying sounds I had a
few people mention the buzzer being a
bit disruptive we might need to find
like a nice gong or something oh I like
the gong idea
they should do that in basketball as
well change it to a Gong
we'll find something a bit more gentle
starting with the next episode Professor
Sean in the meantime sorry about the
buzzers if that annoyed anyone I know
that uh uh well we'll get it mixed in
there in post-production so that it's
not too annoying let's do one more
question from the live stream Alabama
here's a question from Dan can you offer
your advice on item replacement in terms
of balancing environmental cost and fair
trade manufacturing while ensuring the
item will fulfill its requirement
without compromise or repurchase
um
hmm I'm reminded of everyone's been
sending this Jerry Seinfeld stand-up
joke to us I was going to review it on a
talk aboutable segment on the private
podcast but we might as well talk about
it right now
he has this uh actually in fact
Professor Sean I'm sure he can pull it
up really quick and then we could we can
actually talk about the the joke itself
because here's what happens I understand
the concern for the environment but when
we've purchased the thing we've done
much of the damage to the environment
that we're worried about and so one of
the unexpected benefits of minimalism
for me was but by consuming 90 percent
less I probably produce 90 to 95 percent
less waste that was not my intention
when I started simplifying my life it
was much more for me but then the
benefits rippled and all of these other
areas let's check out this quick joke
from Jerry Seinfeld and we could talk
about it
will throw anything out at any time
there's a wedding album I thought you
were done with it
and that was wrong I admit that now
those are special memories and they're
gone now but the point is this all
things on earth
only exist in different stages of
becoming garbage your home is a garbage
processing center
where you buy new things bring them into
your house and slowly crapify them over
time objects start the highest level
visible in a living area from there it
goes down to a closet covered a drawer
that's why we have those so we don't
have to see all of the huge mistakes we
have made in the closet it goes to the
garage one of the longest phases in
trashification no object has ever made
it out of the garage and back into the
house or a personal storage unit this is
the saddest of all now instead of free
garbage you pay rent to visit your
garbage
it's almost as though he's Conjuring the
ghost of George Carlin here yes but he
has this new take on it and yes it is
true that very rarely do we go store
something in one of these areas we hide
our stuff because there's a slight sense
of Shame like I bought this it isn't
doing what I thought it would do or
maybe it did what I thought I would do
but it's not continuing to do it in
perpetuity so I'm going to hide it away
in the closet I'm gonna hide it in the
basement I'm gonna hide it in the Attic
I'm gonna hide in the garage or the
storage locker very rarely do those
things make a new appearance in our home
do we pull them back out and say now's
the day where I begin to get value from
this thing again yeah well there's
something about throwing it away that
makes us feel the loss
right so if I put it in the garage I
feel like I spent a lot of money on that
and I'm still kind of being responsible
getting some theoretical value out of it
by virtue of my ability to imagine some
future day when I might use it but once
you throw it away you got to admit to
yourself
truth that was already true at the time
you bought it it's a loss yeah I mean as
soon as you take it off the shelf like
your the damage is done yeah um it
doesn't I mean I always uh said it and
in this way like hey if you take
something off the shelf it's slowly
decomposing now it's just decomposing at
your place and then when you put it in a
landfill which actually helps to
decompose a little faster I mean if
that's the end result well then the
landfill's actually you know the place
for it but yeah no that is that's a
great bit that must be from uh how long
ago was that I wonder seems like a
pretty new one yeah no idea we'll check
back in with the live stream here in a
little bit but first malibam what else
you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
hi my name is Lisa and I'm calling from
Maryland I really just wanted to give a
comment I have listened to your podcast
for about a year and have enjoyed many
of them thank you and I also just wanted
to make a comment in reference to family
friends and Gifts my granddaughter will
be four in August and my Gen Y daughter
is a budding minimalist and as a result
of that is trying to reduce the number
of gifts coming into her home
so she did a an invitation and indicated
that there could be donations made to
the NICU which my granddaughter uh
resided in for a brief period of time
after her birth or give a donation to
her college fund we were discussing the
backlash that she received from people
that she worked with who came up to her
and told her that she was denying her
child a childhood and a variety of other
rather negative responses I'm proud of
my daughter she's holding tight and
holding fast and will continue to use
this option for my granddaughter's
birthday but it was interesting to
actually see this firsthand as opposed
to just you know hearing about it on the
podcast
yes that is our minimal episode for
today we'll see you on patreon for the
full two and a half hour I think almost
three hour maximal edition of episode
378 which includes a million more
questions from our listeners a private
minimalist home tour you'll take a
shocking tour of my living room you'll
never believe with this minimalist owns
quite literally that's actually true not
clickbait also our notorious obsolete
object segment TK's tweet of the week
and outstanding added value segment that
we enjoyed a bit too much
I wonder
oh my goodness
plus we got much much more of less and
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast the
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play and your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
that's right all of our archives are now
on patreon all the way back to episode
zero zero one and this is a sequential
show you have to catch up it's
serialized you have to start with
episode one yeah if you start with uh
this episode you're just you know
there's so much plot that you're missing
actually I totally disagree I would work
your way backwards yeah and so uh I'm
joking obviously but start with the more
recent episodes if you want to dive into
the archives they're all available for
you over there patreon that is our show
for today if you leave here today with
just one message please
but it be this
love people
and use things
[Music]
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign